imagine this it's a bright sunny morning
and the fields are glistening with
promise today is the day your hard work
finally pays off you're ready to harvest
the fruits of months of dedication but
as you walk to your tractor The Familiar
hum you count on isn't there instead
silence your tractor the very Lifeline
of your farm has broken down you rush to
troubleshoot checking everything you can
but it's no use the fix isn't something
you can handle because the real problem
isn't the engine it's the system maybe
it was something in the fuel system I
changed the fuel filter but it kept
doing
it so then I finally called our John
Deere mechanic and uh he said really the
only way we can figure this out is we
got to hook up a computer and download
the air codes imagine owning a piece of
equipment worth hundreds of thousands of
dollars only to discover you don't have
the right to repair it instead your
forced to rely on the very company that
sold it to you waiting days or even
weeks for an authorized technician to
show up all the while your crops are at
risk your season hangs in the balance
and the clock is ticking this isn't just
an inconvenience it's a battle that's
costing Farmers billions of dollars
every year and it's a fight that goes
beyond broken Machinery it's about
challenging the monopolies that are
stripping consumers of control not just
in farming but across every industry
welcome to the front lines of the right
to repair movement a story of resilience
corporate power and the struggle to
reclaim ownership in a world where what
you buy isn't really yours let's dig
into how this impacts Farmers Industries
and the Very Foundation of fairness this
is the culprit it was just randomly
shutting down first thing we did was
change the fuel filters in it and it
didn't really resolve the problem so I
was stymied at that point that's the
only thing that you basically have the
ability to do without the John Deere
software that's exactly right the
reality of farmers held hostage in the
heart of America's farmlands tractors
aren't just tools they're lifelines yet
when they break down farmers face a
sobering truth they don't actually have
the power to fix what they own packed
with proprietary software today's
tractors require specialized tools and
diagnostic codes that only authorize
dealership can access this Monopoly
forces Farmers to wait for technicians
pay Skyhigh repair fees and worst of all
lose precious time during critical
farming periods take Joe a fourth
generation farmer from Iowa when his
John Deere tractor broke down midseason
the nearest service center was over 50 m
away and it would take a week for a
technician to show up every day his
tractor sat idle Joe lost thousands of
dollars
and even when he tried a local repair
shop they couldn't help John Deere's
software locks kept them out for Joe
this wasn't just an inconvenience it was
Financial ruin staring him in the face
the problem Monopoly on repairs John
Deere one of the world's largest
agricultural equipment manufacturers has
strategically locked Farmers into their
ecosystem their machines once mechanical
Marvels are now rolling
computers this shift means that even
minor repairs often require expensive
diagnostic tools or software only John
Deere can provide this isn't just about
broken tractors it's about control
farmers are at the mercy of a single
company unable to repair their equipment
access their own data or even decide how
to manage their Farms independently and
it's costing them billions annually the
first couple tractors I learned to drive
on didn't have any electric controls it
was all mechanical controls but you know
those old tractors were pretty easy to
diagnose if there was a problem and
pretty easy to fix those problems the
fight for change but Farmers aren't
backing down across the country a
movement is building to challenge repair
monopolies and restore ownership rights
here's how the fight is shaping up
antitrust lawsuits farmers are suing
John Deere arguing that its repair
Monopoly violates the Sherman Act backed
by the Department of Justice and the
Federal Trade Commission FTC these
lawsuits aim to dismantle deer's
strangle hold on repairs I'm just
notifying John Deere right now if you do
that we're putting a 200% tariff on
everything that you want to sell into
the United States the FTC has already
forced companies like harleydavidson and
Weber to loosen their grip proving
change is possible when the government
steps in
right to repair legislation over 30
states are considering laws to give
consumers the right to fix their own
devices from tractors to smartphones
Colorado made headlines in 2023 as the
first state to pass a law targeting
agricultural equipment under this law
manufacturers must provide farmers and
independent repair shops with the tools
and software needed to fix Machinery
other states like Minnesota and New York
are following suit signaling a
nationwide shift Federal action the
Biden Administration has called for
sweeping reforms in 2021 an executive
order urged the FTC to crack down on
repair monopolies including those in
agriculture while Federal action faces
intense lobbying from corporations the
momentum is
undeniable I know America can't succeed
unless American Business succeeds but
let me be very clear capitalism without
competition
isn't capitalism it's exploitation the
stakes more than just repairs the
implications of this battle go far
beyond fixing tractors at its core the
right to repair is about data and
whoever controls it controls the
future modern tractors collect vast
amounts of data on soil conditions crop
yields and Machinery
performance this information is
invaluable to Farmers but is owned by
John Deere farmers can view their data
but can't transfer it to other platforms
or use it with competing equipment
Brands this Walled Garden approach keeps
Farmers dependent on deer and prevents
them from exploring better or more
affordable options it's a monopoly not
just on repairs but on Innovation itself
and until this changes farmers will
continue to lose billions not just in
repair costs but in missed opportunities
to improve efficiency and
profitability you think it's fair that
farmers and ranchers will pay
$300,000 or a million dollar to purchase
a combine or a tractor to not own it
we're not leasing it we're we're buying
that the gadgets that are in it are part
of that equipment and the technology
that runs that gadgets is part of that
equipment we thought when we bought that
tractor that we bought that tractor Lock
Stock and Barrel lessons from the Auto
industry
the agricultural fight for the right to
repair mirrors a similar battle in the
Auto industry in 2012 Massachusetts
passed the first state level right to
repair law for cars forcing automakers
to share diagnostic tools with
independent repair shops it was a
GameChanger but as technology advanced
automakers exploited loopholes claiming
cyber security risks to withhold
wirelessly transmitted data sound
familiar John Deere is playing from the
same Playbook arguing that allowing
third-party repairs could compromise
food security and safety yet cyber
Security Experts have debunked these
claims pointing out that independent
shops can implement the same safeguards
as dealerships the Auto industry
eventually conceded to national
agreements in 2014 proving that change
is possible when public pressure mounts
a path forward so what's next the fight
for the right to repair is a marathon
not a Sprint Farmers lawmakers and
Advocates must work together to push for
federal legislation a nationwide law
would eliminate the patchwork of state
regulations ensuring all Farmers have
equal rights data ownership Farmers must
have full access to and control over
their own data enabling them to make
independent decisions consumer
awareness the more people understand the
stakes the harder it becomes for
corporate operations to justify their
practices Joe's story is a testament to
what's possible with Colorado's new law
he fixed his tractor himself in less
than a day saving thousands of dollars
but Joe Knows the fight isn't over true
change requires Federal action and a
united front from everyone who believes
in fairness and competition farmers and
ranchers we have the highest suicide
rate in the nation and it's because our
occupation is so stressful
equipment breaking down and you are not
able to fix it you can't do
anything that's a whole new level of
stress the road ahead the right to
repair isn't just about fixing machines
it's about fixing a broken system it's
about restoring dignity to Farmers
empowering consumers and challenging
monopolies that stifle Innovation and
choice the battle may be uphill but
history shows that Collective action can
overcome even the most trenched Powers
so what can you do support local and
National initiatives educate others and
demand accountability from lawmakers and
corporations this fight affects everyone
not just
Farmers today it's about tractors but
tomorrow it could be your smartphone
home appliances or even Healthcare
devices together we can break the
strangle hold of repair monopolies and
create a fairer more sustainable future
what do you think have you faced similar
struggles with repairs share your
thoughts in the comments below and don't
forget to like subscribe and hit the
Bell icon for more stories that matter
together we can make a difference thanks
for watching and see you in the next one